[Music]
beautify
[Applause]
vandalism ban or is it
hi everyone my name is welcome to mild
vandalism
yeah the best kind say no to
ass man that's right
no no no no no no dear kid who
graffitied some cool ray pants and um
and mustache on me
i'm not even mad i look [ __ ] good
that rat
mustache looks great on you man i pump
penis
not me ow this video is sponsored
by world of tanks yeah wall of tanks
is celebrating their 10-year anniversary
congratulations world of tanks
that's awesome good for you i made
videos playing world of tanks it's a
really fun game
it's free check it out but before you
check it out
put on a party hat get ready to
celebrate sign up and use
the code pewdiepie and that way when you
start playing the game you get a ton of
stuff for free
you're welcome so if you're already
thinking about playing the game
definitely use the code because then you
get 14 premium days
one premium tank the excelsior british
tier five baby damn
okay all right we're giving away a lot
250 000 credits
where's my 250 000 credits oh wait i got
him because i signed up using the code
pewdiepie
you get to play 10 battles with a long
sincere
that's a swedish tank baby that's gonna
crush it
10 battles with the tiger one three one
that's a german one
ten battles with soviet is6
here eight all the tanks in case you
don't know it's a really cool game they
have over 550 tanks
so whether you like to play with big
peepee or small peepee oh sorry i meant
big
tanks or small tanks artillery light
heavy
small big peepee small pp there's always
a new and different way to play
it's always fun to play i i played it
for hours literally when i did my video
it's really cool
the battles are huge just check out my
video i don't know why i'm describing
the game
and it's also historically accurate
because sweden may have not done much
anymore lately but at least we have cool
tanks alright we got that
so if you're not convinced yet i'll be
uploading a video playing world of tanks
soon but i'll be crushing it with my
swedish chick
and i'll make new history because it's a
bad goddamn time sweden
come on we were white kings once thanks
again to world of tanks for sponsoring
this video
click on the link below to download
world tanks no
voice activated say loudly paper towel
now
paper towel now paper towel now
ain't peter's church it just ain't
so whose charge is it though i don't
know suzanne peters
[Laughter]
massive nice well done
that takes big brain i've echo no no no
no no clap for bacon
paper towel place
alexa totally snappy
i should not have laughed at that that's
awful but
[Music]
speeding what's your excuse helping you
bastards pay for donuts that's right
yeah donuts you like doughnuts you're a
cop you like donuts you love them
you can't have enough with them hey
what's up with that you love donuts so
much
why don't you donate these nuts nuts
our goal is to completely kill the
planet and 99
of bacteria in it for the lowest price
well done
[Laughter]
instant paper cut binder it's funny
because it's
true it hurt ow oh there it is
found it sausage the new fragrance
damn that man smells like some fine
sausage
hell yeah eat a friend heck eat them all
mcdonald's what that flip dude what's
burgers that dish
you deserve a tastier morning than this
oh side cue that
how did they even do that someone must
have had a ladder to do that right how
do you
like you can't do it from the ceiling
that's actually kind of weird i don't
know
oh okay it shows it on the right uh i
just read the equation and
understood the joke chase a bag
chase no ho james bank must be so
[ __ ] done
chase yo dreams that's so
lame chase these nuts
[ __ ] god of that when it comes to
working another day not god
damn it yes i already chased my nuts i
don't need a science film
hail satan really i prefer silk
this feels like the equivalent of
someone writing something mean
but they use a grammatical error such a
dead meme like oh
you're you're stupid without the e and
they're like
you're
i'm not now i'm five
faying sleep and she's
gaying a cab every 20 minutes
a child is diagnosed with
a mustache it's much like on this video
and we can cure a child
these today in case of fire do not use
elevator use fi use water all right take
it back this
is super freaking lame dude police
i will never be able to unhear that now
that's actually funny harry potter and
the influence of climatic legend
legends on the distribution of dry land
fire crushed communities
i love that one that's one of my
favorite harry potter ones
this year thousands of men will die from
stubbornness no we will
that's impossible how do you know that
huh what's the statistic on that
huh oh yeah how many people were part of
the test four thousand
that's not nearly enough for a million
your test is useless everyone on the
planet what am i going to draw some
conclusion out of stats
it's ridiculous
[Laughter]
quite appropriate i would say
that's great when you see flip your
phone meme but you're watching memes on
samsung's smart fridge
i want the samsung smart fridge just for
the memes can you imagine
that'd be epic king of disabled badges
only
the king of disabled badges
wish i was a disabled badgers king bill
pastors will be prosecuted
bill postures is an innocent man he
didn't do nothing
but free bill passers free from
us oh it's an axle auto what are you
gonna do draw smiley
oh wait boy oh he's gonna get a top head
isn't he homie's just vibing though come
on
give him a pipe
vandalism done right uh what the
is a unicorn oh that's cute
[Laughter]
world's smallest peepee yes i had never
been there a statue of saint peter's
feet in
the vatican after centuries of being
touched
what are you serious that's like
when people say in museums and stuff
like that don't touch anything
it might seem harsh but this is the
result it's pretty crazy
these penises are monitored to
counteract
legal activities offenders will be cute
took me a second fine granulated sugar
here you go
can i have some granulated sugar please
fine
wait what do you want do not throw
litter
dollar fine damn then put a [ __ ]
garbage can here
fine okay they're okay with it
didn't realize it was fake until i
started clapping at a water fountain
clap activated
that's fun that's epic prank
why did that took me so long god damn
i'm slow p
limit 25 there's a limit
i've been doing it wrong boner wait yeah
it's funny because here in uk all the
streets are so [ __ ] weird you don't
need to vandalize them to laugh at them
there's cuck street [ __ ] way ugly woman
road
legit this is just from the top of my
head hey spanker lane
haha road are you serious
butthole lane excuse me uk
follow me i gotta go
i gotta go to butthole lane right now
but holland how far is it for me lee
leechester oh that's not too far
that's worth it i gotta go right now
titty ho
hell yeah kitty ho car dealer i know
where i'm getting my next
automobile vehicle dumb woman's lane
there it is i've drove and passed it
i knew it was real i was so confused
when i saw it on the gp hit that
woman's leg what
yes dumb woman dumb
it's a bench
why is that funny i don't know bench
poop with friends poop alone the choice
is yours
choose wisely you ain't lived until you
poop with your
bros that's hysterical that's so [ __ ]
fun all right let's do a couple more
lame i still laughed i don't care no man
oh wow okay
hell yeah
[Laughter]
hell yeah that's how i was done
epic oh that's a big pp right there
[Laughter]
to whomever is placing googly eyes all
over the office
please stop thank you
oh that's great
that's kind of fun i'd be confused if i
saw that
well hidden too think big vote small
i'm small vote me help me please i'm so
tiny
please please i waited
45 minutes and no employee came to wash
my hands
or wipe my ass i remember doing that
when i was in kindergarten
i waited at the toilet my parents never
taught me
[Music]
for the kindergarten teacher to wipe my
ass
i'm sorry kindergarten teacher i i was
taught
i wasn't trained i apologize for making
you
do that to me and my brain should
apologize for keeping that memory god
damn it
why am i sharing this all right end of
this video uh look at this graph
subscribe see you tomorrow bro face yeah
[Music]
you